a refugee camp in northern afghanistan
filling up with frightened people
they have fled to comparative safety as
the taliban continues to gain ground in
other parts of the country
claiming territory and control as
international forces complete
their withdrawal the violence is getting
worse
and the un is warning of an imminent
humanitarian crisis
there was war bombs were being dropped
my father
was killed there and a lot of my
relatives were killed as well
and we had to flee i was responsible for
my children and i didn't want them to be
killed
so i came here with my elderly mother
up until this point the taliban have
been advancing easily through rural
areas
but now they have their sights set on
three major cities
pushing to re-establish an islamic
emirate
lashkar is particularly vulnerable right
now
it is the capital of helmand province
and where many u.s and british soldiers
lost their lives
kandahar is being targeted too tens of
thousands of people have already been
displaced
in herat afghan special forces have been
deployed
and it's believed civilians have been
mobilized to take on the militants
in three provinces the security
situation is critical
especially in lashka the enemy has some
movements
security and defensive forces are
planning to intercept the enemy's
movements first
then build defensive lines and later
launch offensive operations
with no peace deal in sight afghan
citizens continue to suffer
this hospital bombed by afghan forces
who believe
taliban fighters were being treated
there
hospital was bombarded but there were no
taliban in the hospital
there were only six staff members from a
total of 40 staff members working with
us
and they were pharmacists and nurses and
two of our nurses were wounded
a patient's caretaker was martyred and
another patient's caretaker was wounded
and a few days ago the un office and its
staff
were also caught up in the fighting
by september almost all foreign troops
will have left
afghanistan if its government cannot
find a way to fill that gap and
quickly the future for this troubled
country and its 38 million citizens
is far from certain hannah thomas peter
sky news